well I feel like we should start this
week by welcoming a bunch of new
listeners thanks to the unbelievable
amount of publicity that last week's
Ronda Rousey podcast got [ __ ] man
they said steve-o's Wild Ride podcast on
TMZ Yahoo News ESPN
it was everywhere so once again thank
you Ronda because last week's podcast
was epic and this one's no joke either
plus my co-host Scott Randolph having
some symptoms feeling sick he went to
the doctor to get a corona virus test
and the doctors said that it was
negative I think the doctor might have
also said he's a [ __ ] but I'm not sure
about that anyways it's me and my
co-host Scott Randolph in the van and
doing it for the Jackass fans this week
with wee man
so let's get to it yeah yeah ladies and
gentlemen it's wee man yeah yeah yeah
dude what's up
I'm so excited thank you for doing this
hell yeah first off and this is probably
a dumb question because I think I know
the answer but what's the official
spelling of wee man w ee ma n no - now
it could go either which way I've lately
like for years now I've just been doing
capital W EE then capital M am with the
space for no space no space Wow dude so
there is controversy surrounding how to
spell your name without sending the link
yesterday I was trying to figure out
like I was looking at Steve's like text
message threads like how does he spell
it okay cool cuz if I send that he's
gonna be pissed my words pretty cool is
just recently Motorhead is doing
t-shirts that you can custom order with
your name on it
but they want to put the umlauts like
how Motorhead has AHA and Motorhead it's
the second oh that has louts so in my
name it says there we eat Louie ma n so
it's pretty rad
alright that
pretty cool way to run with it Motorhead
style
if there is an over-under for how long
it would take to start singing the
praises of heavy metal like which is why
I made your thumbnail the the logo out
of a grinded up independent truck you
ride independent right I read Andy's
yeah and these are the best I mean
there's not much every other truck after
that you know just there want to be in
these and we what we want to keep the we
want to keep the laymen in the loop the
trucks on the skateboard and this and we
never sponsored by independent Trucks I
was never that they don't have much of
like it may be your core team but the
rest of the people aren't independent or
just flow they flowed me and he's still
guys they yeah yeah you don't have to
pray a paper tricks right okay yeah so
those are your true love's skateboarding
and heavy metal it's safe to say yes
yeah yeah and how do they smell we man
on John the beginning of Jackass I feel
like it's we - man yeah they've done
that they I think they've done multiple
ways it's good
so yeah I'm so particular about how to
spell steve-o it's like I don't care
what anybody calls me people ask me all
the time - it is it Steve or steve-o or
Steven I'm like I'm not particularly at
all I don't care what you call me but if
you spell steve-o with a capital S and a
lowercase O it drives me nuts
it drives you can you can do a lowercase
s and a lowercase o as long as it's all
even but you can't [ __ ] capitalize
one and not the other and I gotta have
the - dude I got a how do I get stem Oh
what did the first time I did the tattoo
I accidentally misspelled it Steve oh
because I was so loaded alright starting
that sent out I mean I'm gonna try to
keep this move in with questions
comments of get the listeners stoked and
I knew it
I know that there's been like many times
over throughout the history of Jackass
Wildboyz you name it whatever
we've been doing we've thrown out the
piece of information that you speak
fluent German but I'm guessing still
people don't know that is that I think
yeah no still it still comes up like
I've gone on trips I was previously
sponsored by Monster Energy and they
would send me all over the world and I
went to Germany one time and the lady
who was with me like you know hosting
there whatever was there and she's like
I've been with you all these years and
we'd landed in Germany and I just
started talking German to the people
there and she's like I never know you
spoke German I'm like well you never
asked right and and if I remember
correctly GERD from Italy I was born in
Italy right so my I'm an army brat my
dad was in the army he was first
stationed in Germany where he met my mom
and then he got transferred and
stationed in Italy and that's when I was
born I was conceived in Germany
but born in Italy got it it was German
your first language no it's my second I
didn't even want to learn it when I was
a kid but I did learn it really young
you know you're a kid and you're asking
your mom what's this my mom would tell
me in German and I'd be like no not that
funny language what is it some of the
[ __ ] they were saying they're like my
balls how you say pull on my balls
I don't know balls like like it isn't
kitchen coochie no kitchen is kooky kick
in kitchen cooking is cooking and
kitchen is q-10 okay say say like a
sentence I give us something
pointing ma hey I'm here okay pointing
behind flies in the queue here all right
that sounded pretty good but say but I
want to hear like some naughty [ __ ] like
[ __ ] is schiessen right [ __ ] sadly and
we've always made jokes about it's so
crazy because we don't know you speak
German like most people but everybody
think we can't say enough about German
schiessen movies what's the story with
German schiessen movies because German
like the Germans are like the Nadia sir
they're like that they're like the ones
that'll do the like [ __ ] on my face and
stuff like that
that's where it's come from that's why
shiza movie came from that aha [ __ ] on
my face in German shell phone call just
touch it really quick for a second
well kiss it for things like keeps a
4-iron stick on okay is that yeah yeah
okay so people know people are generally
not aware that you speak German but boy
does it seem evident that everybody
[ __ ] knows that you were living out
of a van oh yeah you know this is gonna
be good but first I've got to tell you
about my balls and spill the beans on a
very big secret so in this quarantine
nobody's going to see their barber
everybody's growing out being a SAFF
rose myself included but there is no
reason why anybody should have a pubic
afro let alone shaggy balls so I'm very
grateful that this show this week is
sponsored by manscaped who has us
covered to make sure that our balls are
nice and groomed without getting cut now
what's the big secret
the secret is that when the quarantines
over and people can congregate again I'm
going to be having a massive meet-up
where I want every dude they can get to
Los Angeles to bring their manscaped
lawnmower 3.0 grooming
- this made up and we are gonna harvest
the biggest pile of everybody's pubic
hair that we possibly can but hair
included so that's the secret you don't
need to know what it's for or when it's
happening but what you need to do right
now is go to manscape comm use the promo
code steve-o to get your grooming tool
as well as all kinds of other products
that manscape makes to keep dudes on top
of their game and again use the promo
code steve-o at manscape comm for 20%
off your order
and free shipping and make sure you hang
on to that grooming tool for the mass
roundup and harvest of pubic hair again
go to manscape com use the promo code
steve-o for 20% off your order and free
shipping now back to wee man check this
out like I think you've told me ahead of
time think you are gonna do a YouTube
video with the guy who's got like an RV
channel or like a campervan YouTube
channel and that channel I don't know
what it is now it had 15,000 subscribers
where you gave a tour of the van that
you were living in legitimately living
in it and it's like it's almost five
million years yes and I've had people
come up to me and be like dude we men's
living in a van and then because
especially cuz I had a van so it was
just like oh how long were you living in
the van I lived in it for one year I
actually got to during the time period
that I lived in it so the first one when
I went to go get one when I realized I
wanted to live in a band uh they're like
well it was back in September of 2018
and they're like well we can't build you
and have a dental July of next year and
I'm like dude I just sold my house and
I'm kind of stuck and I was living in a
hotel for like two months and so they're
like we'll look on our website and see
if someone's still in one use
and this was a Thursday afternoon and I
look on their website like oh that one's
pretty rad let me call the gate so I
called the dude and I go hey view any
bites on your van you feel well got one
god but you see like come back and I'm
like well I'm gonna be there Monday he's
in Arkansas I know I'm gonna fly in
Monday I'm gonna take you to lunch and I
want to sneer van in person he goes all
right sounds good I'm like well don't
sell it because I'm interested
he goes okay sounds good he had no clue
who I was that's mean don't sell it I'm
interested yeah five grand of the price
just off that comment he had like a bro
boner once I got there and he realized I
sold my house now I'm kind of stuck me
that's like you it sounded to me like
you were like dude I sold my house I'm
moving to Canada I'm gonna live on a
farm
that's not his first can it happen yes
okay so I'm not moving to Canada anymore
I changed my mind and I already sold my
house so yeah is that why you decided
that you wanted to live in a van yeah
because in 2018 the muck this the real
estate market was kind of high and I
knew I didn't want to buy an LA again
and I wanted to do something bigger so I
was like [ __ ] what am I gonna do so I
just started researching bands and I got
stoked on the Mercedes Sprinter one so I
started checking them out and checking
them out and I actually called my buddy
who I knew rapped him and did different
things and I'm like what do you know
about these I need more info and when I
texted him he actually sent me a photo
he was driving his he's like come by in
the morning
I'll tell you
about oh yeah yeah I did my whole
research before I went and got one now
when you were living in the van for that
whole year like where would you
typically most often sleep like where
would where would you park it mainly
like campsites that like RVs would camp
at uh-huh yeah I was kind of sketched I
did a couple like I did quite a few
times like they would say Walmart
parking lots Cheryl yeah and then like I
did Flying J gas stations because in the
morning you could go in and take a full
shower and all that yeah get whatever
you need so I did those a few times and
then after a while I just I kind of got
tired of wondering where I was I had a
toilet in my band
aha and I just hated taking a [ __ ] in it
and then having to clean it out you know
so funny I love the luxury of having
that what I had is the cleaning part of
it we with this one we've got a toilet
right here we piss in it but we don't
[ __ ] in it yeah it's a compromise yeah
no no I I would do that all the time
like I didn't care about that yeah every
morning you know you wake up every
morning you got a drop of juice
I know I know you do you're the most
regular guy I know you and you drink
your coffee and then that makes you [ __ ]
every time every morning that like you
you don't do that now I do that every
morning well I don't know you as well as
I know hey Jenny did you ever have any
crazy experiences like sleeping over at
night some of these places in like the
middle of America like people knocking
on your door or [ __ ] it was all
pretty mellow he was pretty stealth yeah
I was pretty stoked about it okay I'd
like a plain black hmm yeah I wasn't
like I didn't have my I didn't have the
yeah dude logo on
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I was did you get the app on your phone
called iover lander which is like gps
and in the end it just marks spots where
you can get away with with sleeping in
your car overnight I've never got that
everybody kept telling me to get it and
then people kept I heard all kinds of
apps and I just like most of time I
would just say [ __ ] it and just go
somewhere and I'd kind of like figure
out spots but it was tough every morning
trying to find a plate like I'd be like
okay go to a coffee shop get a coffee
and you know take a [ __ ] there and then
I kind of go from there you know and I'd
like figure out my day I mean like as a
guy who's had a van first had the little
camper van and then I got this you know
big motorhome which of course for the
people listening we're in it right now
this is what I got I had the camper van
then I got this big motor home for like
podcasting and stuff dude it is it's
gnarly moved to actually commit to
living in the van yeah I would never I
don't think wanted to do that I you know
what it did it humbled me I totally got
humbled from it knowing that I could
still survive with a minimal amount of
things and still get to do what I wanted
to do like for the first while I
seriously was traveling and hit in
different skate parks and I was loving
that part of it the only part I didn't
like was I thought I I thought I could
handle like every day I'm waking up film
it see this
it gets old trying to do that when
you're like no I just want to show up
and I just want to skate so that was
work but it is very living in it is very
humbling because you don't know what's
right outside of you and
you know you never know you know I one
of the best experiences I had was I went
to a campground in Sedona Arizona up in
the hills and so I came from like sunny
Southern California went up and it was
raining that night and they said it was
gonna snow and so I had a little fire I
was looking up at the mouth at a creek
by me the next morning I woke up and I
opened the side door and it's just
snowing and I'm like this is the best
life I'm just sitting here having my cup
of coffee taking my share that's killer
I miss it he's got it man now sorry I
don't have it and my lady and I go all
the time we'll leave on little band
excursions just just for fun she loves
it too yeah it's it's awesome I I won't
get rid of this van I will always keep
this van yeah just give I like getting
away right now
there we are under the subject of ladies
and congratulations for getting engaged
thank you thank you yeah I'm stoked
we're both engaged I've been engaged for
it over two years now I would that your
engagement when you got engaged
yeah you were there when I did I love
that man so is it true that like you
know she's the one when you got it like
how'd you how'd you know she was the one
so I mean like I would meet different
girls different things and all that and
a lot of dude like older dudes and dudes
they've been there like you'll know what
she's I'm like you know I've met so many
girls I've never had like she's the one
so her and I have dated before we've met
multiple times this last time when we
got together the first night we hung out
I knew it there was just this thing I'm
like we're supposed to be together
you're the one I know and we have been
ever since we got back together and
what's funny is I proposed to her one
week before everybody got put on like
stay home like I proposed her March
first and then like March 12th everybody
was on lockdown so we've been at home
everyday that's like yeah but the big
test it is dude that's right never
thought this coronavirus thing that's
what I've heard
of course there's a lot of things about
it but couple's divorce rates spiking
I heard divorce rates have spiked
different like all kinds of things have
happened
it does test it does test the
relationship and yeah I'm enjoying the
[ __ ] out of your barbeque videos every
night yeah what's crazy is right then
too I just went by my buddy's house I
said let's go to this barbecue place
because Judas the headquarters so I went
there and the dudes were pretty stoned
and I saw this barbecue I want and I'm
like well I want this small when I got a
little small order it for you and once
again coronavirus had a kind of a thing
on it where the shipment was a little
late but as soon as it went in I jammed
over there got it and I said you know
and as soon as I got I go you know what
what else do I have to do but I can cook
on this thing every night so I just
started cooking and making different
things and learning different techniques
and I was making fun videos just watch
me chop
flames were blazing instead of just
cooking on be right did we load it so
much it's like the bet you know it's
it's it's an enlightening thing during
these times yeah so everybody you're
cooking on Instagram every night and
everybody needs to follow you on
Instagram it's oh yeah I am wee man yes
you'll know that's a blue checkmark
that's right it's seen it seems like
there's been some what less skating that
you've been posting on Instagram is it
safe to say that because here with your
chick that that that's making you skate
a little less no not at all for first
off was right before we started filming
I got injured really bad like oh yeah
that's right I put my calf super bad and
then I got back into and I started
skating with my buddies again and one
week before we started filming I bashed
my knee pretty hard and I was like oh
dude I can't I just cruise right now
while we're filming but then with this I
was gonna just start cruising around
and skates well there's all kinds of
skate spots my house but it was raining
and different things so I just started
doing other things in the mean time so
it wasn't my lady it had been anything
but my own time in my own I wanted to
make sure I was in the healthiest point
for us to film good I didn't want to
show up to set with a broken leg yeah
Jeff I'm here you know I get it now I
just think it's so killer that you've
skated so consistently so passionately
for so long and I gotta say to you that
you know you're aging fantastically well
thank you yeah you know the Jackass guys
we have we've all kept our hair like
what are the odds what are the odds that
like you know yeah like nobody's gone
bald Yeah right
yeah see if we were what if we were one
of these podcasts where they're bringing
it up I would say like bring up for sure
the percentage of men who go Bob but I
really I really like Knoxville's post
the other day where he's shown his gray
I was like dude he looks better it looks
great because it is matte it's how he
should look right now they say what you
know when you dye your hair and do
everything it's not where you're at with
your body your body's color tones change
with where you're at in life so he's
like he's he's the sexiest he'll be
right now for sure I mean do you have a
lot of Gray's I got like a couple that
just go through here I don't know but
that's all this is all natural
that's so funny when we used to say
natural humping a chick with no rubber
skinny dipping
yeah I want I want to get into that but
I but I feel like I can ask those later
cuz I'm curious because don't don't try
this at home
bunch of times I went on to four years
four years yeah yeah we've had a lot of
history man it's a it's really
incredible I think that about Jackass
what's particularly cool and and makes
me grateful is that you look at all
these rock bands that have been around
forever and they just hate each other
you know like like they hate each other
but they keep touring and stuff and like
legitimately I think that the the
chemistry and the magic between us with
jackass is like the same as it ever was
yeah and that's it totally is and I've
actually grown better throughout the
years the chemistry has matured and
gotten even better right and it's crazy
too because the the the movies for
Jackass were so essentially few and far
between you know like I said yep there
was four years off in between each of
the first three again mouths 10 right
and you know it's it's crazy how like
everybody kind of went different ways
some of the others some of the guys
didn't do anything and like what's so
impressive about you is that you've got
like fully into like being an
entrepreneur my god it's it's it's it's
crazy like how much did jackass 3d with
the the wee man's chronic tacos logo
that they included in the film how much
did that launch your your restaurant
enterprise it launched it huge it was a
big success I hear about it still to
this day because films forever
so somebody watching it last night will
see the way man you know Ryan done
jumped sponsored by women's chronic
tacos and you didn't even have to do the
jump you've already gotten in to that
deal right and I was already in I'd
already been in two years deep once the
movie hit and it was just one restaurant
that had
yeah was that Newport no that was
Redondo Beach and we did it we did it
just for fun and Knoxville would drive
by it all the time when he used to go to
Naomi's house so he said when he first
saw the sign go up he sent me a picture
he goes what the hell's going on and I'm
like yeah just doing what I do but it's
not the first chronic tacos no no no
there was 28 at that time oh [ __ ] okay
so what should when you here's what
happened
so in 2008 the founder came to me and
asked hey do you want to join chronic
tacos we're kind of either in the middle
of gonna sell the brand or maybe revamp
it and he goes I've seen you you did
some cool things I think he could be a
cool face work and I said well let's
meet you know discuss so we met and then
we had a great time we hit it off me
he's such a rad dude his name's Randy
and we GE goes dude let's the one you
open let's call it we manage chronic
joggers like alright I wasn't even
involved in making that decision I just
wanted to be part of the brand and we
did that and then it kind of it spiraled
from there right what I wasn't clear on
was what why you had your name on one
restaurant but you actually have like
some kind of involvement in owning all
of them right you've got like a share of
it yeah I am a 10% of the whole thing
and now there's 50 restaurants no
there's 62 well oh [ __ ]
added like 12 in the last few months are
you guys killing it right now is it are
you guys taking a huge hit with the rona
are you guys worried about it we're
we're taking a huge hit with the rona
we're I can admit that we're chipping a
blue this but it you know we're doing
like everybody else's curbside pickup
and deliveries right now you know how
you guys do a lot better it would be
doing some hot sauce for your butthole
inside of each story
I mean if you can make some decisions
that's what I can talk about it I mean
how many different styles of your own
hot sauce you have we have two or three
different styles I mean you could - that
lingers Preston like when your
restaurant business really took off he
said yeah we got a new name for wee man
he's rich little I feel like it's
shocking nobody would ever believe like
that actually like the jackass guys have
like reasonably high IQs you know for
the most part pretty good decisions I
think like with with money with business
you know like and the housing market
yeah oh my god dude with the house funny
is I've actually been reading finance
books lately too and and I've got some
pretty good advice and big changes that
once once this whole thing kind of goes
through there's gonna be some big
changes to happen and I want to pass the
word on to it especially like my bro's
good man I trust you another thing is
that so you've got a lot of love for the
military because I always hear about how
you travel all over to do these as a USO
yeah there was so appearances yeah I
mean how many times have you flown like
overseas to do USO stuff I can't even
count anymore I know it's been over 10
or 15 we've done it but we did it for
seven years straight
and then I've always always for free
yeah yeah and then I've gone around the
world clockwise on two different trips
in one week in eight days we'd start in
LA fly to New York New York till then
like Italy Italy then to like Germany
Germany like Afghanistan then like in
we'd go clockwise in eight days and just
different troops out in different areas
are you flying like a military plane
yeah we actually we've flown a couple of
times on Air Force two the vice
president's plans so we've flown on that
twice and then it's like yeah then we've
flown on c---seventeens the big ones
that carry tanks and stuff and all kinds
of different aircraft
what's the vice president's plane like
oh that thing is tits just think of a
private jet but 747 sighs yeah if it's
Air Force two you would imagine it's
probably the same [ __ ] thing as Air
Force one right yeah yeah exactly yep so
how many how many of these USO trips did
you go into just full-on war zones I've
been in three I believe I went I went to
Afghanistan and Iraq during the Iraq
Afghanistan wars we are in we landed in
Afghanistan and they told us if we tell
you hit the deck hit the deck like all
right we're doing 30 30 minutes oh my
gosh yes we didn't even spend the night
there we only stayed for like two hours
and when we took off back off we had two
f-18s flying with us ready to shoot
anybody down like it's the papal holy
[ __ ] so crazy we would go with a
four-star general who would take us on
these trips man and then the scariest
thing ever that I've ever been and we
were in Afghanistan and we're gonna hit
fly to Qatar and we were in the rain it
was morning rain we were getting in the
helicopter in the rain and we took
four military helicopters takeoff we're
ten minutes into the flight and we look
out the window and we see shoe shoes and
we're like oh shot at and the pilot gets
on yeah we're gonna have to turn around
due to weather because we just got shot
at that's gnarly dude ya know it was one
of the scary things a bit like to be
actually shot at you're like okay this
is gnarly all right if we're talking
about scary things like I mean I hate to
be asked a cliche boring question but I
think if it's me asking you it's kind of
a dope question like a scary jackass
moment like some of the gnarly I don't
know because I've been asked that
question a whole bunch of times and I
don't know what the scariest thing is we
get fright because we've been around
with wild boys and stuff - we've been at
around anaconda snakes on us you and I
have laid Tigers we've I've jumped off
bridges with tide depressed in you know
so there's this thing where it's like
I'm more of an adrenaline junkie than a
fear junkie because you're just
desensitized doing should say that I'm
embarrassed for asking that question in
the first place because I get the same
[ __ ] so much all the time - and I always
kind of stick with the same answer that
when it comes to scary situations like
you know you max out at a certain you
know it said ones not scary there
because once you're scared to a certain
point yeah there's so many different
examples of times where we maxed out
that you know it's apples and oranges
and yeah yeah I think for me like
something that I would never do out of
like anything that you guys have done
would be when Manny grabbed the tail the
[ __ ] lion did right
that's heavy metal right even though
even though
was a captive lion you know I don't mind
it's like going to Tiger Lane I can't I
don't see it's kind of hard to fight the
the hot the danger of okay it's a
captive lion sure great because you can
you'll see Siegfried and Roy yeah go
into cages and go well yeah we're cool
cuz they're captive and do dot you know
right I'm the tiger king yeah the tiger
[Laughter]
get the biggest thing with the Tigers
was a straight-up [ __ ] vegetable
because the tiger just [ __ ]
chomped his head like a [ __ ] cheeto we
were filming with the same captive Lions
in California doing this Nintendo
commercial and we're I'm up in the tree
times we just straight up could have
died and that's like for sure one of
them but I was making fun of Siegfried
and Roy in the tree and then comes up he
was making you he was linking you like
he was like oh this is a good piece of
meat and after this third time were you
there
no but I've seen the Fiat I wasn't there
but I've seen any city kept reading bro
like what was going through your mind
one of the times if you guys almost died
if you could think about he didn't die
but one of the fun ones was when we were
on the back of the elephant meters and
steve-o and the elephant just took
I mean it wasn't that bad but it's a fun
one
that's times I almost died while working
like for work and then times we almost
died like you know like I honor our
personal time yeah yeah I try to
thinking like I mean in South Africa
that was pretty crazy but like I mean
any other like Fiji swimming with sharks
wasn't that bad yeah I don't know why
like bull sharks in different parts of
the world aren't as crazy but enough of
all that
now on the baby before we start
recording I brought this up like with
the the political correctness the this
whole culture of being really sensitive
and really careful and like it always
felt weird to me like in jackass and I'm
pretty sure that it was included in like
the final cuts of movies episodes right
if I'm not mistaken where they're
throwing around the word [ __ ] and like
here's here's a funny one it's the word
has never bothered me because I've gone
back to the day like I think people have
always asking you've been bullied or
whatever or anything when you're I'm
like no and I'm like if you ask Preston
Preston he will tell you I'm the biggest
bully
so words words have never heard me like
that I'll even say [ __ ] but what's a
funny thing to me was in jackass 3 when
we did the big hand for me to bring BAM
towards me he was walking in the office
and he had his breakfast burrito and he
was walking in and I was doing the
foosball I said to him in his voice to
kind of get his attention like hey
what's up [ __ ] you know so I asked BAM
and I was in the cut nope
they blurred it they beat it okay what
are you doing I'm like that's how I
that's how i lure damn right to the hand
and there no no paramount said no can't
use the [ __ ] where
whatever and I'm like I'm the one saying
it you know what I mean right
you know realistically I think that I
could argue and I really do believe that
what's more offensive is the actual
politically correct term little person
because I think that that is inherently
belittling you know to say like to see
like you know I've already said I don't
give a [ __ ] how tall we man is there's
nothing little about he's [ __ ] epic
but here's the only way that I took it
to in that I think the general
population sees it I did Kevin and bean
one time too and I okay
are you cool with [ __ ] or whatever and
I'm like yeah but I'm like your [ __ ]
did whatever yeah they had two little
people on and they got very offended by
that word that Kevin and bean just kept
saying it to get under their skin and
they say you know it's like yeah well if
you let it if you let it get to you it's
gonna get to you if you don't let it get
to you just go when I was doing cocaine
with Mike Tyson locked up in a bathroom
for like hours on end he said one of the
most insightful things ever he said the
definition of the n-word is anybody who
uses the n-word that was pretty deep one
of the best things I've loved about
Tyson and one of the best thing is that
he he comes out real low and then went
real high so he came out with just a
Chow on you know a one-note as his as
his music didn't have the stool and then
he would just knock fools out and and
Jerry said he hates when comedians
they're just comedians would come out
and do like a firework show you know
Flying Tigers and stuff and then the
comedian comes out he's I know you got
to come in low and then go high
yeah I was always with my tour my first
stand-up I didn't want to come out to
like some like big epic entrance song
because I'm gonna stand there and talk I
would want it to be like kind of goofy
Christopher Cross jackass things where I
forget what it was for but they were
gonna hate you I think with a fish and
it's really hard to stand there and get
it was for the super slow-mo camera yeah
we did it for the intro right that was
your intro shot I came for that for the
opening scene like and especially at
like 1500 frames per second like you can
catch any little move and get hit with a
[ __ ] fish in the face like a big
heavy fish like it's really hard to know
you're gonna get hit and not know I
flinch at all and so so they're trying
to get the shot and and and you know
your instincts like you know you're like
okay anticipating it for Drive I never
liked music and they put on like some
iron made and there's some Black Sabbath
and you're like you know it wasn't
helping at all and I was like hold on I
got this and I got running and getting
my little Nissan verse and I pull it
into the [ __ ] hanger and I opened up
the doors and I played Christopher Cross
sailing you just relax
I thank you for that because Jeff was
getting pissed he said hey man just
stand there you know you see this like
right here is where you get the glitch
and that's where you move right it's
like when you were when you were with us
in Thailand filming Wildboyz and someone
said think it was probably you you said
hey you know where we are
and and I'm like I don't know and you go
Bangkok and [ __ ]
it was like the greatest nut shot but
somehow like they didn't get it right on
camera so then it was like oh we got to
reshoot it but now all the sudden we
know that we're gonna get hit in the
nuts
we get like [ __ ] epic footage that
you never got on camera and it's just
like dude if I only [ __ ] have that on
camera
is there any like thing that you I think
there's a gun yeah I have a lot of skate
stuff like that where we never had the
cameras around or rolled not like damn
yeah throwing myself up a balcony yeah
yeah that's not on camera that's a
pisser don't we're so dude like have you
you're something where people's people
ask me like what's done you get this
question so much what stunt did you
regret and I haven't answered the same
answer every time is like my honest
regret is that I didn't do more that's
why mine too because there wasn't really
any that I didn't do and then the one
I've also answered is do you remember
when I think it was in Florida I forget
who was had the little baby alligator
and it bent knocks on the nipple they
came to me first and I was like uh-uh
and then Knox gets and he has this full
poster now and I'm like [ __ ] I could
have been a bright man that there were
like so many times were like I didn't
step up or I did but I have fasted a
little deeper and got the [ __ ]
footage I would have been more stoked so
you know and then I just get so starts
to not if I can give up because I'm like
that like that's why I keep going man
that's why too so it's pushed me more
now because of those times that I've had
regrets now I think about him when I'm
doing other things
right and without without being too
particular about like what we're up to I
think that it that I'll just say in
general that I really believe even
though we're way [ __ ] older that this
thing we're talking about where it's
like dude now this is like last call
it's last call if I couldn't be gnarlier
than ever and the bar is higher we've
gotta [ __ ] push harder and go bigger
and just be gnarlier I agree with you
100% I think that I sure like a lot of
people might think who wants to see a
bunch of [ __ ] middle-aged drunken
like knows what's gonna happen with this
coronavirus [ __ ] dude it's so heavy it
is I mean what are you hearing are you
thinking we get back into the economy
what in the summer or later or earlier
I mean I'm hearing I've heard certain
things that's like end of May that I'm
hearing into June July and there's
there's so many different things the
economy you can't trust and that's why
I've been reading finance books lately
but if you look if you watch the stock
market every day it's like it's green
one day or two and then it's red
straight down and then it's great it's
seriously like this and that's like okay
that that is just that's the worst like
you can't follow that and think it's not
like oh it's slowly going up and there's
a little dip and then slowly no it is
this all day long it's what you call a
dead cat bounce banks like the [ __ ]
you know the power people they're like
let's inject a bunch of money and to
give people confidence in the market
they put it in and share it comes up but
then the real [ __ ] slam comes I
watched a documentary on the stock
market crash of 1929 and say I can looks
like exactly what's going on now yes so
heavy like this morning
like I look like the analytics on the
[ __ ] podcast and and I noticed that
with when I was talking to Ronda Rousey
and I said something about I think that
this could be like not only like a Great
Depression but a greater depression I
think that was the point where like a
lot of people like [ __ ] that I was on a
podcast radio station this morning I
just like to have buddies at this radio
station in st. Louis and they're like so
you know what's up like you're gonna be
on tour and I was like dude tour like
society society as we know it it's like
on the like is maybe never gonna be the
same because as far as touring goes
there's two components like it's the
question of after this coronavirus deal
how soon are people going to be
comfortable to be packed into a room in
large numbers in small spaces and I
think that's a variable and even if
hypothetically everybody's totally cool
with it
like after all of this economic shutdown
like how soon can you expect people to
have expendable income to go out for
like at an expensive night at the the
theater though yeah yeah that's just an
extra thing first they got to give back
and make sure whoa this is the first
spam risk call I've got a virus do you
ever notice when riscos went down that
was a spam risk call how about that yeah
all right I haven't received one in a
long time but that was the first one
there they heard us talking about the
[ __ ] economy crash movie theaters are
shutting down I think AMC's going
bankrupt like the movies it's gonna be
it's it's [ __ ] heavy dude that whole
plan that you had to move to Canada it's
up there too it's up there also
like it's all over sure and Canada's
particularly [ __ ] because the price of
oil is down
like 20 bucks a barrel or something it's
like yeah saying like in Canada's whole
economy is that but I don't know that
people are too interested do you got I
just said I you know just thinking about
it and I was you know I knew that you
came from Italy in Germany over to the
South Bay and then you started working
as a subscription guy another spam call
is that what that that was a real call
that's nerd okay and and just like you
started selling subscriptions over a big
brother yeah that's that's what you get
and then did you guys know each other
just some people no big brothers the
skateboard magazine which served as the
the genesis for jackass so what happened
was I was already like in Big Brother I
was already in the magazine Ric Kasich
already done a photo shoot I've already
did an interview with Shaun Cliver and
been in the magazine but when I first
moved out of my house and the first
place I lived I lived with Kasich oh
okay Kasich was like well you got to get
a job you just can't just skate and so
then I went and worked at big brother so
it was a subscription guy do you go and
get like people to subscribe no no no I
get all the stacks of magazines and I'm
just shoving them in envelopes and
putting people's addresses that were
subscribe to them and then mailing him
off did like now Big Brother magazine
started as this like crazy escape thing
and then like the guy who started it
sold it to Larry Flynt
so at Larry Flynt being like the the
founder of Hustler magazine like the
world's most but that's Larry when
jackass starting to well sort of my the
first date the first issue of Big
Brother magazine which I was in was the
first issue which was published by Larry
Flynt and that came out when I was in
Clown College in 97 so that was with the
one I was on the cover of because they
changed it and they sent when it went to
Larry Flynt and Larry Flynt got it they
sent off the Big Brother subscriptions
to some dude who had oh porn mag right
that sounds gonna say it was
boo taboo magazine which was like yeah
taboo magazine taboo magazine was like
the the most risque like the most edgy
likes like the taboo means like not okay
my mom so everybody who subscribed to
Big Brother got a copy of taboo magazine
which is just like [ __ ] up in it in
the tank
yeah yes so then it made it to Jay Leno
and that issue was the one I had my pro
spotlight in and I was on the cover
doing the Oompa Loompa skating that we
filmed for to do jackass ah I was gonna
say was it super you the one stuff in
tappers and saying like my brother was
working that Big Brother and he'd bring
home all the taboos and keep him in my
room
his where was Steve the intern yeah
Chuck Liddell and so so my mom walked
into my room and I was like 14 or 15 and
there's just stacks of taboo and she was
like what the [ __ ] are you doing dude
yeah yeah yeah he's a sex addict most
times you've come din one day we man for
the audience seven I'm always interested
in that because like highly successful
people are like highly sex driven so
it's like I'm always curious about that
and and when I was like buddy
who did 11 one time when we were kids
and then we had like hooked it up and we
found out but like the more you do like
the higher the number the crazier you
are so yeah crazy is not necessarily a
bad thing no it's not it's not at all
hey it's just a term so what are we
promoting I think the people who are
still
listening at this point deep in a
podcast art and by the way thank you to
all of you people who are still
listening
they're like the diehards man these are
the people who are these are the people
who are like yo they don't want to miss
a thing whether like steve-o's my guy
we man's my guy you know like they're
they're on our team they support and and
we love them and what is it that we want
to promote like for you
I don't have nothing promote I dropped
all my skate sponsors you know I just
you know I lit I promote things now that
I love ha ha go eat at chronic tacos
tacos order to go order it to go yeah
follow me man on Instagram actually
follow me whether you're listening on
audio or on YouTube and watching it take
a screenshot of your phone or your cake
a photo of your computer and tag we man
in it and tell them how much you [ __ ]
love to the podcast and confirm confirm
that you're following we man on
Instagram and tell them to add some hot
sauce for your butthole to chronic talk
[Laughter]
kind of like causes charity kind of
stuff like are you particularly
passionate about I'm passionate but like
for chronic we do no Kid Hungry so it's
all the kids yeah we donate to that so
it's like food banks and different
things for kids that yeah especially
like in now time to start our literally
like thousands of cars like if they can
even make it a line it's got to be again
oh my god so [ __ ] I want to figure
out a way to help get like get behind
some Food Bank stuff that's the best one
exactly for the kids
yeah it's not you know it's not their
fault that you know the economy's like
this and all that and stuff sure right
yep but 59 minutes and 13 seconds
I was like gold I think that's probably
a good length man I don't know yeah I
want to say to thank you for thank you
for so so much dude like for being there
from when I went to finish the
skateboard the wall ride for just being
a bro like we had some some meetings
prior and prior to this big big thing
we've been doing yep right we met for
being there when I engaged to my good
guy when I proposed to my girl like it's
really crazy man like like just about 20
years
yeah you know I like to think that we've
been there for each other and really
grateful for your brother Thank You bud
I'm really grateful for you 382 and I
think sometimes when we we don't think
outside of the work box and we realize
even we would do things outside of it we
kind of thought of it it is work I think
we forget that how much we've been bros
and been doing throughout these years
yeah thank you thanks for being my bro
to but we were also talking before we
started this whole thing that you're
interested in firing up like a podcast
of your own which I'm totally supportive
of and I can you know everything that
I'm learning from doing this I can
easily transfer over to you and I think
it's fun I think it's a killer NATO the
things I'm learning too I'm gonna
transfer over to you tears I know when
when we're all when we're getting a
little older and stuff you'll have this
nest egg set up that you'll be like I
can do whatever the [ __ ] I want
I mean see what happens man like we'll
start with the hot sauce and then we'll
work our way into stock I'm sure
everybody else too
yeah another incredible podcast in the
can and like I said during the podcast
please screenshot that [ __ ] tag we man
and myself on Instagram and I love that
we're doing that every week sorry I'm
working out it's like you guys are the
street team just promoting it to
everybody to listen to the podcast check
it out on YouTube super grateful for
that and I mean [ __ ] yeah I don't know
what else to say it's a lot of fun I
think we are gonna actually go every
other week there now but every week
something's going on we'll see what it
is and I love you guys thanks yeah